فايز الدويره الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
وسانطلق مما قاله زاور قبل قليل وهو
استعمال كلمه او مفرده التمرد
اذا سلمنا بانه تمرد عسكري فعلا ما الذي
يمكن ان ينجر عليه
يعني اذا كانت تمرد في اي دوله في العالم
وخاصه دوله روسيا
تتميز بالنظام المركزي يجب احتواء هذا
التمرد ويجب انهائه والقضاء عليه وبالتالي
تاريخيا
التربيه العسكريه منذ ما قبل الثوره
الفلسفيه ومنذ زمن الجيش الابيض ومن ثم
الجيش الاحمر بعد الثوره الفلسفيه
ومرورا في فترات تستالين وما بعد هناك نوع
من العنف المفرط في التعامل مع هكذا احداث
وبيت سيبيريا تشهد على عمليات التهجير
القسري ليس فقط لمن يرتكب الجرم انما
لعائلته ومنطقته وبالتالي اذا كان هذا
الادعاء صحيح وان تحريك القوات باتجاه
روستوف وغير ذلك وثبت ان هناك نوا حقيقي
لابد من احتوائه ولابد من التعامل معه
بجديه الان العلاقه الشخصيه ما بين
بريكوجين والرئيس بوتين وطباخ بوتين
ودعوات الزعامات عالميه الى سلسله مطاعمه
اعتقد لا ترقى او لا تقف هذه هكذا علاقه
في وجه تحدي خطير في وقت خطير على على
القوات المسلحه الروسيه اذا دعني اقول هو
لا يقول بالانقلاب يقول بتصحيح المسار
ولكن ما معنى تصحيح هذا المسار هل هو بصدد
فرض املاءات على الكرمليل ان تغير
القيادات العسكريه التي هو لا يرتاح
للتعامل معها واتهمها بامور كثيره اعتقد
ان هذا الطلب اكثر مما يقبل او اكثر مما
يحتمل ولكن كان ملفتا في البيان نقطه
عندما قال
عدد القوات 25 الف ماذا قصد بذلك البعض
فسرها على انها نوايا من اجل تنفيذ انقلاب
انا افسرها بمقاربه مختلفه كليا هناك
تقارير واضحه ان عدد قوات فاجنر 50 الف
وصل 50 الف الان يتحدث عن 25 الف فكانه
يخاطب ويقول انا قدمت 50% من قواتي
لمعالجه
فشلري وبالتالي من يقدم خمسين بالمئه هذا
ابن الوطن يدافع عن الوطن هذا يسهر على
حمايه الامن الوطني انا قدمت 50% من حجم
القوه قتلوا لتسكير الثغرات بسبب فشل
شويغو وفاليري فبالتالي هو كانه استخدم
انا احلل كانه استخدم هذا
ليقنع بوتين بمصداقيه توجهه وبانه وطني
ولكن هذه الجماعه هي تعيق العمل هي ورطتك
يا الرئيس بوتين في حرب خاسره قدموا لك
التقارير بان العمل سينتهي خلال اسبوع الى
عشره ايام والان مره اكثر من 16 شهرا ولا
نزال في الوحي الاوكراني ولولا قوات فاجنر
لما لما تم استعاده السيطره على سوليدار
وعلى
اذا اردنا ان نعرف على الصعيد العسكري
وناخذ الكلمتين بمسافه وبنوع من التحفظ
التمرد والانقلاب في الحاله الاوكرانيه
وفي الحاله الروسيه الان ما الذي يمكن ان
يعني هذا وما الذي يمكن ان يعنيه ذاك
يا سيدي عندما نتحدث عن انقلاب نتحدث عن
اطاحه بالمنظومه السياسيه
وتغيير البنيه
والتركيبه
الكيميائيه للدوله تغيير نظام حكم عندما
نتحدث عن تمردنا نتحدث عن مطالب دون ذلك
ان تتمرد وحده عسكريه نتيجه ظروف قاهره
رفضا لواقع سيء وبالتالي هي لا تسعى
للاطاحه بنظام الحكم لا تسعى الى تغيير
كيميائيه الدوله ولكنها ترغب في تصحيح
مسار خاطئ فل انا ارى ان هناك فجو
من المقاربتين الانقلاب العسكري وما بين
التمرد ولكن كلا الامرين هو خروج على
القانون خروج على الدستور بغض النظر هذا
الدستور وهذه القوانين تلقى القبول او لا
تلقى لكن يبقى الدستور هو الكتاب المقدس
لاي دوره لاي دوله في المستوى الدنيوي
والوض ولكن عندما نتحدث عن تمرد عاده
نتحدث عن
قطاع معين من داخل المنظومه العسكريه
نفسها يعني مثلا عندما يصف الجيش السوداني
قوات الدعم السريع بانها متمرده على اساس
انها خرجت على المنظومه الامنيه والدفاعيه
بالنسبه للحاله الروسيه الان في اوكرانيا
هذه شركه خاصه يعني مقاول خاص ان صح
التعبير كيف له ان يتمرد على المؤسسه الام
المؤسسه العسكريه
يا سيدي حتى هذه حتى هذه المنظمه الخاصه
حتى يعني حتى القوات الدعم السريع ليست
موضوعنا وقد يكون لي اجابه اقول الان حتى
هذه المؤسسه الخاصه هي تم تاسيسها بناء
على شروط معينه
وتوظيف معين
ولتحقيق اهداف لكن قوات فاجنر قوات فاجنر
استخدمت الدوله الروسيه لتحقيق اهدافها
خارج الجغرافيا الروسيه فبالتالي نجدها
ذهبت الى سوريا
ذهبت الى مالي
ذهبت الى ليبيا
ذهبت الى السودان
ذهبت الى الكونغو وبالتالي اصبحت تحقق
موضع قدم للدوله الروسيه في هذه في هذه
الاماكن وكلنا نتذكر عندما ذهبوا الى
ليبيا كيف كان رد الافروكام القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه الافريقيه وبالتالي
انتبهوا الى انها بدايه التمدد الروسي في
هذه المنطقه اذا هذا التنظيم او هذه
المنظمه الخاصه كانت بالتناغم ومن خلال
التوافق والتكليف تقوم بتنفيذ مهامات
اوليه
لا يستطيع الجيش الروسي بحكم التوازنات
الدوليه ان يقوم بها فكانت تذهب بحجه
حراسه مناجم الماس ومناجم الذهب وغير ذلك
ولكنها كانت تنزل
اجند او تهيئ لتنفيذ اجنده الجنسيه الان
اصبح لها وزنها بدات العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه بدات الانتكاسات في الجيش الروسي
حدثت في كييف في خار كيف في خرسون
وبالتالي كان لابد تم التعبئه الجزئيه
ورغم كل ذلك لم يستطع الجيش الروسي ان
ينجز ما هو مطلوب منه فماذا كان البديل
كان
وهذه فاجنر انعكاسات اعداد الخسائر من
قوات فاجنر اقل تاثيرا والى من على الشارع
الروسي من خساره 25 الف جندي على سبيل
المثال لماذا لان هؤلاء بعقود خاصه جاؤوا
بمل ارادتهم معظمهم اربعين الف منهم من
السجون ذوي اسبقيات الجرميه طلب منه انه
تذهب وتقاتل راس حربه لمده سته اشهر وتصبح
الان طليق وتذهب الى طي صفحه وبدا به صفحه
فبالتالي هؤلاء هم في الاصل جماعه خارجين
على القانون
الاجتماعي من خلال عمليات القتل والاغتصاب
والمخدرات
ستبقى معنا لوفي